tom seaver and tom seaver was special to
me as a as a young baseball fan i used
to be a big baseball fan tom seaver was
one of the first baseball players i was
ever aware of
when i was a kid right when you're just
five six years old and you're starting
to learn about sports that's one of the
first names i ever heard is one of the
first baseball cards i ever had he
passed away
this week at the age of 75 and the mets
had an interesting tribute to tom sear
they put
dirt on their knee because when he
pitched he got so
low with that right leg that it would
get dirt on it during the game
that's how he how committed he was to
getting the most out of his arm
the wind-up and the follow-through
resulted in dirt on the knee so a great
tribute a creative tribute
and that's what we're going to do today
the best nfl tributes that's our draft
and this one was kind of challenging
because when matt casey suggested it
yesterday shereen you and i were both
like
really this isn't going to be easy and
then once we started thinking about it's
like you know this is going to be fun
so we're going to have some fun now with
the best nfl tributes of all time
shireen asks me the question i'll do the
cindy brady routine and not come up with
the answer and she'll end up with the
first pick what do you got
well i'm actually going to give you a
choice of two and i came up with this
one on my own and i thought it was
fitting for this and and
there's two two possible answers so it's
almost like
what is the color blue who you can
either say
who was the first player to spike the
ball in the nfl or who was the first
player to start
the end zone celebration and either one
of those answers will suffice for this
trivia question
the first player to spike the ball and
the first player to do an actual end
zone celebration there have been so many
over the years i don't know when it
started it's always been part of
football but i'll tell you what the
first guy
that i think of when it comes to a
celebration is billy white shoes johnson
was he the first one to do the end zone
celebration
he was he was not the first one so the
first player to spike the ball was
giants receiver homer jacobs in the
vintage year of 1965 for obvious reasons
and the first one to do the end zone
dance that's came four years later elmo
wright actually did it first at the
university of houston
and then he brought it to the nfl with
him uh with to to the chiefs and he
he is credited with starting uh the end
zone dance that would have been in 71
uh with the chiefs but he did it in
college before that
how in the hell are either of those even
remotely regarded as easy questions
i've been following football for 50
years and i had no idea on either
i've never known either one all i know
is this for anyone who was born in 1965
you are damn
oh i was born in 1965. that's was
shireen but i was born later
um all right you get the first pick
thank you for giving me that very easy
question that makes me feel so foolish i
didn't know the answer to either part of
it
okay so so there as
mike said there are so many of these
and it was a fun exercise to figure out
which
one of these to pick and i've ended up
with so many it's hard to figure out
which one to start with and
and they're fantastic fantastic
answers to this question but i think i'm
going to start with
with the sean taylor missing man
formation
after sean taylor died in the in the
first game back
washington went out with 10 players on
defense
in a game and with the realization that
sean taylor wasn't there with them
and it was a sad moment but a moving
moment at the same time and
and i think that was one of the greatest
tributes didn't care what happened on
the first play
it was a tribute to sean taylor and to
this day we still remember who sean
taylor is we talk about sean taylor
and of course he was murdered um in his
house and
in an unfortunate incident there but but
no one has forgotten sean taylor and
washington are really in the nfl
just an amazing talent and a guy who was
in the process of turning his life
around when his home was invaded by
would-be robbers and
he was shot in the leg in the artery and
bled to death
and it was a great and fitting tribute
by the washington football team then
and it really is a shame because he was
destined to be a hall of famer and he
played with an intensity that was
inspiring
it was fun to watch he made the safety
position incredibly great and when you
think about
him ed reed and troy palomalo all would
have been
playing that position at the same time
for all those years and i think sean
taylor may have ended up being the best
of all of them if
if he had been around to fulfill his
full potential all right
the first one i think of what i think of
an nfl tribute and this has been going
on for a long time
you know usually when there's someone
connected to a team in a high profile
position who dies
we see the jersey patch or the helmet
decal for one year
and when george hall has passed away in
the 80s
the bears made that
gsh a permanent part of the stripes
on the side of their jersey and it's
always going to be there
and it's you know and and he deserves it
and i've argued that that
like like george halas don shula even
though he didn't found the dolphins he's
so connected to that team that they
should have a permanent
honor for him in the uniform not just a
one-year thing but the gsh
on the the uh the sleeves of the bears
jerseys is
you know i i thought it was awesome at
the time and the fact that they
continued to do it all these years later
and will always do it
um you know a fitting tribute to one of
the most important figures in the
history of the sport
yeah absolutely when you think of the
bears you think of george hallas and
you see that patch and another one in
the history of the nfl you know this
generation
of kids don't remember a lot of those
guys but i think everybody knows who
george
george hales is just because you see
that patch and then you know his history
of the team and so that's a very good
one and i had it on my list as one of
the top ones too
god there's just so many to do um i
think
somebody's gonna go with seattle that's
the way sims buys time
go ahead right i think i'm gonna go with
seattle and the 12s their tribute and of
course they can't use
12th man because there's a a great
college of course
the trademark of course
and that would be texas a m my alma
mater but i just like the tribute that
they have
the fans they retired the number 12 with
the organization nobody can wear that
number
they they started the tuition in 1984 of
raising the flag
uh for the 12s to to tribute to the fans
and i just like that tradition of the
fans especially in seattle which
you have to say is one of the best home
fields in the nfl
uh that we've ever seen and you you see
the the
the false start penalties that the
offenses have because those fans are so
loud and i just think it's a great
tribute that they've done in seattle for
the fans
yeah you know i was going to say they're
wasting their time doing it because as
we know there's no competitive advantage
to having fans in the stands so i don't
know why the seahawks would attach any
importance
whatsoever to uh the the impact of
their fans on the ability to win
football games because again there is no
competitive advantage
to having fans present uh and if we say
it enough times maybe to eventually sink
in
all right the next one for me the
perpetual flame and they're taking it to
the next level
in what what uh mark davis calls the
death star
and i really you haven't watched the
star wars movies if you think death star
is something to aspire to be but the new
stadium and i had
one uh one reader point out that it
looks more like a roomba but either way
in the new stadium they've got this
3d laser printed eternal flame of al
davis and they've had it
for every year since he passed in
oakland and now they're going to have an
even
bigger monument to al davis and
apparently the flame
isn't an actual flame they've got some
technological way they're doing it but
that's always going to be there that's
always going to be in that stadium
that's
always going to be connected to that
franchise that tribute to al davis
who you think of you think raiders you
think al davis
and uh it's just an amazing tribute
uh and look at that thing look at that
torch that's al davis and that's the
impact he had on that team and he's
going to loom over that franchise for as
long as it's in the nfl and for as long
as the nfl's around
yeah no question about that and and and
again
it's another great owner that they've
managed to to give a tribute to
you know he started out as the nfl afl
commissioner and
and has gone on and and did great things
for the raiders and
and now we're going to remember him uh
for forever and raiders fans certainly
know who he is even though he's been
gone for a while and i think that that's
a fantastic tribute
um i'm gonna go with neil smith just
because it's a great story and if you
remember his
his celebration it was for george brad
or we thought it was for george bratt
the way he would swing the baseball bat
when he after he got a sack and the way
it actually started was
he was watching jay leno one night on a
friday night
and jay leno did a golf swing and he had
been looking for some sort of
sac celebration and says that's it
that's it that's what i'm doing i'm
doing a golf swing
and so they played a monday night game
and he said he had three three and a
half sacks and he decided at the time
to do the golf swing and so he did it
after every single sack and of course
it's on national tv and everybody saw it
and some reporter asked him
after the game was that a tribute to
george bratton he's
and he said i just said yeah it was a
tribute to george brett even though it
was intended to be a golf swing
and all of a sudden it became this
tribute to george brett and kansas city
and of course
the kansas city fans loved it and that's
what it turned into and it was years
before he
actually told the real story that it
wasn't really a tribute
uh to george brett but that one was just
so fun
uh that it turned into something that it
didn't start out to be that
uh it was a great story i'm not up on my
late night show trivia but i think it
was johnny carson who did the golf swing
shireen and since you and i are of the
same one he said
he said jay leno and when the story i
read
said jay leno so yes but you're right it
probably was carson but he said jay leno
he's which makes it an even better story
he doesn't even have the right guy that
inspired the golf swing that became the
baseball swing for george brett actually
jay leno actually
johnny carson and by the way if you're
watching this on peacock when the show's
over
there's a bunch of great old johnny
carson shows which
it's amazing to see the the comedians
who are on there the guests he had
the joke and a lot of topical jokes that
i don't know what he's talking about
because it was it was funny at the time
because it dealt with something going on
at the time but it's not going on now
but it just gives you a flavor for how
the late night shows
used to be and they're really not all
that different than they are now all
right next one for me
i'm torn on this but i'm gonna go um
i i'm gonna go when when wade phillips
showed up at super bowl 53 with his
dad's hat and jacket
that to me was just incredible the bum
phillips 10 gallon hat
and that big old jacket with the fur on
the on the lapels
uh the tribute to his dad even though
wade had been to a super bowl and won
one before there was just something
magical about that moment there's so
much about the connection between
fathers and sons and parents and
children in football whether it's
watching the games going to the games
working
together that to me resonated and i
i wish a bigger deal had been made of it
at the time
i got to give warg done some love before
we go because
you know this is a guy who has a great
tribute to his mom and he just gave away
his 181st
home this year i was there for the first
one that he gave away
and he started this in recognition of
his mom betty smothers who was murdered
she was an off-duty
police officer and was ambushed and and
murdered and he started this
this holidays for homes program and and
it just turned into a huge thing and
and so i wanted to mention him he was my
honorable mention
uh for this thing if we had had a fourth
one because i i think something like
that is worth mentioning to the great
things that he's done
yeah i also had uh jerry glanville
always leaving two tickets for elvis
presley that was a tribute in a
in a weird sort of way uh and jerry
glenn one of the all-time great
characters in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports